l'auteur de la fusillade à paris
porterait un bonnet noir et une doudoune
bleue l'évier stib sli clair quand les
meufs sort des trucs de leurs
soutiens-gorge tu fais pitié
merci alors que dans sa tête c'est voilà
c'est normal ja nouvelles de votre
caisse on la teste direct mais qu au
[ __ ] les graphismes et sons ouvre mon
gars eh bien non c'est aussi recommencer
la télé je me suis bien fait avoir c'est
vrai que j'aimerais la meuf tu as été
vraiment j'avais vraiment envie de
l'avoir déjà dans cette boîte est devenu
plus tard c'est 300 et 3 tout ce qui se
passe entre nous la réaction des gens
quand ils jouent à mario kart
[ __ ] chier ah non
ne rentre jamais ça y est je sais enfin
d'où provient le petit sens du chat
facebook et c'est hwa lee
c'est parti pour un mot de jeunes qui
n'existe pas c'est quoi ton truc moi mon
truc c'est la déchire
norman à trappes
voilà près cette blague j'ai un gros
plan sur le front parfait nickel c'est
parti pour une séance de dédicaces
à
aujourd'hui on va essayer d'apprendre à
parler arabe avec norman norman or si je
te dis one two three tu dis viva viva la
fiesta la violer moi quand je m'ennuie
je suis le poteau
gay soit blues nickel hines ward
j'étais calme enfin à quoi ils
ressemblent maintenant mais servi oui
aujourd'hui j'essaie de rouler un tic
tac
de calories caisse voici ma blague
préférée
ça n'a pas du tout marché
bon j'ai pas trop de budget mais je peux
éventuellement vous donner une
fourchette